hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today's lesson is about
alternative splicing now first let's
talk about what is regular slicing in
splicing is a post-transcriptional
process in which introns are removed and
exons are joined together what does this
mean this means that in a pre mRNA
transcript is made in the process of
transcription and that eukaryotic cell
there are introns are non-coding regions
exons inter coding regions the introns
gets wiped out just a few students
because in this is out within and for
intervening sequence X and the exon fans
for expressed sequence of the exons are
joined together into the matura
transcript now alternative splicing is a
regulated process where there are
multiple protein isoforms that can come
from the same pre mRNA transcript so
these multiple protein isoforms are
encoded by a single gene a via exons
parser exon or enter on being
differentially joined or skip now let's
look at a picture of this right here we
have a mRNA transcript it needs to be
spliced the exons are the parts that
have different colors pattern so and a
white portion or the intron so the
introns get spliced out some of them are
degraded some of them are some of them
have regulatory processes which we'll
touch on in just a minute
so the exon you see there's four exons
here and in this example they can be
differentially joined or skip
differential this is one of the reasons
why it's internet with alternatives
whitening is differential splicing that
they can be joined
skip in different ways so for example in
visits in this isoform we have this
exons this exon and this exon that this
one has been skipped in this isoform we
have this exon this exon and this icon
so this one has been stacked so an
alternative pointing you have situations
for multiple protein isoforms with two
shown here and often even more than two
can be encoded by a single game and this
occurs because exponent or even
different parts of exon or introns can
be joined or skipped in different ways
resulting in a lot of different
combinations
so this isoforms and this I perform
further that these are still mRNA
transcripts they have not been
translated into protein yet so they do
code for different proteins now because
this mRNA transcript and this mRNA
transcript has different sequences in
fact that they have different sequences
means that once they are translated at
the ribosomes and the protein those
proteins have different structures now
the structure can be related for example
they both have this component here they
both have this component here although
in this one they're separated in this
one is together this one has a different
component at the front so they got
different structures related structures
but certainly with differences and these
different structures can lead in
different functions
[Music]
and so you can have different protein
isoforms that are all from the same gene
but because of alternative splicing they
can carry out different functions in the
cell and I also want to take a minute to
talk about the fact that in humans as
many as 95% of multi exon genes that
means gains that have more than one exon
in a transcript so 95% of multi iconic
gains are alternatively spliced so this
process is a very very common one in
most eukaryotes including humans and the
really great thing about alternative
splicing is that it's very very much
increases the diversity of proteins
encoded by the genome because you can
get completely Union proteins that or
they might have related structures we
have different functions all coming from
the same gene and this is why the human
genome was first first sequenced by
Human Genome Project scientists were
very very surprised shocked to find that
such a small portion of the human genome
actually codes for proteins and so much
of the rest of the genome is regulatory
be a pool of junk DNA but we know now
that that's not true and people thought
was such a small portion of the human
genome code for proteins how we get so
many proteins and then we learn about
alternative splicing and suddenly it all
made sense
let's talk to Siri briefly about the
mechanism of alternative splicing it is
highly highly regulated it's not
something that just sort of goes off
randomly it is regulated in part by
sequences within the mRNA transcript I
said earlier that when the intron gets
lice out sometimes they're degraded but
other times the introns themselves such
as it's a sequence of nucleotides can be
highly regulatory they can inform other
component
and acting in this mechanism on how to
act where to cut where to join also
there are various proteins that play
roles specifically two types of proteins
the first are activator proteins the
second are repressor personals and you
can do what you might think the
activator proteins activate certain
aspects the repressor proteins or press
certain aspects and this controls which
places get cut which places get skipped
which places get joined and also a major
component of this process is a large
complex of RNA and protein that work
together this complex is called the
spliceosome and the spliceosome works
along with you just activate your
proteins it's activated repressor
proteins which repress it to go and cut
in the right places and join in the
right places to get these different
transcripts that eventually lead to the
different protein isoforms so that is it
for this video on alternative splicing
if you're interested in learning about
post-transcriptional modifications like
regular sizing also sideburns capping
the 3-prime poly a tail we see my video
on post-transcriptional modification of
mRNA and i fit for today thank you for
watching